[Musique]
la prostate c'est une glande qui se
trouve sous la vessie et qui va servir à
fabriquer la majorité du liquide séminal
et en fait elle a la particularité
d'être au carrefour
urogénitale et voilà elle est enfin
c'est que les hommes qui ont une
prostate les femmes n'en ont pas
[Musique]
platénome de prostate c'est juste
l'augmentation du volume de la glande et
qui va venir gêner finalement
l'écoulement des urines et c'est ce dont
se plaignent majorité des patients qui
vont venir voir l'urologue c'est plutôt
avoir des troubles urinaires la deuxième
pathologie c'est le cancer de prostate
et pour lequel la majorité des patients
vont pas avoir de symptômes mais ils se
soigne très bien en fait on a une
incidence qui est à peu près stable avec
des taux de mortalité qui sont plutôt en
baisse notamment justement par rapport
au dépistage précoce
[Musique]
les recommandations de dépistage pour
une population générale c'est à partir
de 50 ans mais si vous avez dans vos
identités familiaux plusieurs cancers de
prostate des cancers du siens chez
plusieurs apparentés ou une origine
aussi afro antillaise en fait il va
falloir faire un dépistage plus précoce
qui peut commencer à 45 voire 40 ans en
fonction des facteurs de risque
familiaux
[Musique]